[Applaudissements]
versez du lait dans un coca gratuit le
coca devient transparent m une bougie
allumée dans une tasse versez de l'eau
dedans encore et encore la bougie ne
s'est jamais éteinte mettez une bande de
papier en feu dans une bouteille mettez
un hub dans la bouteille elle lui fait
avaler dans la bouteille placé trois
bouchons de bouteille sur un aimant rond
placer un morceau de verre sur le dessus
et mettez un gyroscope en rotation
retirer lentement le vert le gyroscope
tourner dans l'air fixés un ballon de
baudruche rempli d'eau le père forêt
c'est comme si l'eau était retenue en
place c'est le phénomène de l'écoulement
laminaire
ok ceci est une descente de police je
suis pas festival et le suisse thomas
enders
ok c'est une descente de col dont je ne
suis pas triste imac bernard biando
[Musique]
je pensais qu'elle a voté pour toi j'en
dis souvent
la magie
c'est ici
10 e par l'oreille
écoute heureux
comme dieu m il n'y a vraiment aucune
raison de trader
[Musique]
[Rires]